Gruul is probably the worst color combo
for control in all of magic. Really any
of the other three colors alone probably
has better tools than green and red
combined. So, what does it take, mental
illness aside, for someone to attempt
the blue play style with green and red?
Hello, this is Chin with Next Level
Commander and today we'll talk about how
we ended up with the conclusion that
control is the best game plan for a
particular Gruul Commander. Actually,
I'm pretty curious. Have you seen
someone play Gruul control? What's the
Commander? And why are they doing this
to themselves? Well, today the card in
question is Rath and Mikey. And most
people, including myself, when we see a
card like this, this is what happens in
our brain.
>> [music]
>> This is normal and healthy. But my
friend Seb is the opposite of that.
Actually, he's probably one of the best
pre-modern pox players in the world and
even made a YouTube channel dedicated to
it. Uh, check him out if you're into
that stuff. Anyways, so Sam is also a
long-time polymorph enthusiast. So, when
he saw Rath and Mikey, he had different
thoughts. To sum it up, less is more.
Because with this kind of effect, every
extra creature we include is just
lowering our consistency. Rather than
unpredictable chaos, Sam wanted to build
around a cohesive game plan. Oh, and
speaking of plants, I have an affiliate
link, though. Yes, for deck boxes,
sleeves, and a lot more. It is a really
interesting and unique brand, Kakapopo
TCG. Check out their site. They have
some sweet designs at excellent prices.
Yeah, excellent prices and I was talking
about plants. Yeah, plants. Yes, yes.
So, I've been using these deck boxes
from them and they're genuinely really
high quality and I have no plans of
replacing them anytime soon or ever.
Nice. Smooth. Link down below. Also,
there's a code for 5% off. Okay, so the
conclusion Sam ended up with is extra
combat enablers, cards like Raphael, Tag
Team Tough, and Port Razer. Now, this
makes sense. Hitting one of these would
reset our Commander for another hit and
possibly again. With Rath and Mikey
being seven power, the possibility of
straight up killing with Commander
damage is very real. Cool play. But the
problem is these are the two creatures
that do the thing, and that's it. No
other extra combat creatures energize as
well with our commander. So, we have to
dig a bit deeper. We ended up finding
Moraug. I'll be honest, this card makes
everything a lot more awkward. Uh for
example, we have to remember to always
play our land drop in the second main
phase, always. And, this guy is also a
large part of the reason we are
conservative with casting our commander.
Ideally, we only do it with some mana to
spare. But, we are willing to jump
through all these hoops because when
this card goes off, it ends games. And,
we have a ton of ramp spells. Also, for
this deck, I decided to go with
off-color fetches. But, even then, we
only have three creatures. That's not
quite enough, so we had to go a bit
deeper with extra combat spells. Only
the best ones though, full throttle,
great train heist, overpowering attack,
and savage beating, and seize the day.
With any of these in hand, we can reset
Raff Mikey and go for another round. One
problem though, the turtles are seven
mana already. We won't have much to
spare. So, as a solution to that, we're
bringing in two more creatures in Old
Gnawbone and Ancient Copper Dragon. One
hit from these and we'll most likely be
mana positive for the turn. Two hits or
more and we are straight up taking over
the game. Now, hitting one of these when
we don't have extra combat in hand is
not ideal, but it's still crazy value
for our deck. And, that's all for
creatures, just five. Nothing else makes
the cut. Okay, to be fair, Blightsteel
is probably more than good enough, but
I'm just not a fan of the way it kills
someone out of nowhere, but there's
nothing stopping you. But yeah, five
creatures and every single one is bomb.
As long as we get the turtle trigger, we
can threaten to kill one person,
possibly more. Cool play. But, if you're
good at math like I am, you probably
realize this does leave a gaping 90-card
hole in our deck. No more creatures, but
any other card type is fair game. That
sounded pretty exciting until I explored
this color combination a bit more. Turns
out Gruul is literally only good for
creatures, and is crap at everything
else. Garbage planeswalkers, awful
artifacts, mediocre enchantments with no
synergy whatsoever, and I guess that
leaves us with instants and sorceries.
Now, don't get me wrong, those are crap,
too. But, control actually makes sense
here. Sure, we don't have the best
tools, but we do have mana advantage.
And our commander is a really lethal and
consistent finisher. So, Ruric and Mikey
control is somehow where we landed.
Ramp, control the board, keep our
opponents down, and and they will always
have to play around the threat of Ruric
and Mikey coming down and wrecking their
life totals. Gruul control is seriously
happening. You know, I'm always a
Progenitus worshiper at heart, but
playing this guild and feeling
intelligent at the same time is not
something I've experienced. But why not?
Gruul players can be smart, right?
>> [clears throat]
>> Well, you see, this is a library
and a rack of scrolls.
All very academic stuff.
So, with these we can do the top deck
manipulation, which synergizes with our
off-color fetch lands for additional
draw filtering. Not to mention the
possibility of resource conversion where
we can store away the creatures we end
up drawing for cards we actually intend
to cast. Life's stream's blessing and
return of the wildspeaker may seem a bit
counterintuitive in a deck as creature
light as ours, but we do reliably deploy
our commander, which usually comes with
more. Card advantage is absolutely
crucial in any control deck, and
recursion is what we excel at. We
maximize the mana advantage with
season's past and praetor's council.
This room here is also excellent with
the aforementioned collection of fetch
lands. Crow's and reclamation here is to
shuffle our creatures back in case the
skirmish is prolonged. Once in future is
still the best instant speed recursion
spell that allows the adaptive
maneuverability of setting a card on top
of the library if we happen to recur a
creature. And now we arrive at the crux
of any robust control strategy,
interaction on multiple axes. The stack
is of course our domain with Tibalt's
trickery, and that's all we have.
Okay, but for permanence we disrupt
their play pattern with pieces like
beast within, chaos warp, and we break
card parity with the likes of force of
vigor and guff rewrites history. But of
course, in a deck that transcends
creature-based game plans for the most
part, board wipes is how we completely
topple their board state inertia.
Domri's predation, Ugin, Vandalblast,
and reckless endeavor all have their
price, but the off-turn response window
is where games are won. Clearing the
board with a Starstorm or Delayed Blast
Fireball and deploying the control
turtles immediately after is where we
close out games. With such a high cost,
high impact, commander protection is
necessary, but only in moderation this
time. Except for ramp. Resource
accumulation is where green out paces
any competition, especially when the
ideal juncture to deploy our commander
is with some mana to spare. All optimal
mana choices, except Thematic Compass
maybe, but we are all aware of the
importance of consistent mana threshold
attainment. Also, a few ritual effects
for some early game surprise escalation.
And just a few pieces of miscellaneous
utility, Sapling Nursery to take
advantage of the constant terrain shifts
and constant mists for a protection and
opponent morale degradation. For lands,
we play Wasteland enablers for Flash and
Cactus Preserve for a tactical 7/7. An
Ancient Tomb since we are firmly in
bracket three already. Why not? Still,
we have just one more game changer slot,
too. I I guess The One Ring fits our
archetype pretty well. Oh, and as
mentioned earlier, we are going to go
full fetch lands because of how crucial
this guy is to our game plan. But also,
we have a synergy package. And just make
sure we have enough basics for the ramp
spells and we are set.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay.
There's the list. And now, let's go over
the game plan a little bit, particularly
involving Raff Mitey. Here, timing is
everything. If we can blitz with them
very early on, we usually take the
opportunity. But if the board state is
more developed, I'd rather wait till we
have eight or nine mana than dropping
them ASAP. We only drop them when we
feel relatively safe from interaction
and when at least one opponent is open
to attack by our weakest creature, Port
Razer. Now, if you're completely out of
gas, but have tons of mana, I'm sure you
can drop them to test the waters or even
as a blocker. We need to be flexible,
but for the most part, the moment we
drop the turtles, we are nearly
guaranteed to hit one of the big three.
The Minotaur will likely win us the game
on the spot, while the dragons will
provide us with enough mana to cast an
extra combat spell. But yeah, timing,
timing, timing is everything. Play with
the deck a bit, it will take some
getting used to. And there you have it,
the Gruul deck that strives to be more.
This deck is genuinely really strong,
capable of crazy explosive starts, while
still able to keep itself in the game
well into the later phases. It's not the
easiest to play and the pattern does
take some getting used to again. If you
want to optimize the deck, it won't be
cheap and the budget is used on some of
the pretty important pieces. And this
deck sits firmly in bracket three.
Oh, and I should mention this from the
original creator of the deck. Sam is
firmly against soaring and refuses to
include it in any deck. Instead, he
swears by need for speed as something
you drop the turn you're ready to win
the game. So, take that into
consideration, I guess. All right,
that's all for the deck talk. And
remember, if you love life and want to
be good to yourself, check out Kakapopo
products with my discount code. And if
you don't, check out Sam's channel.
I'll see you later.